we're here with Nadia again and we're
going to talk about the stages of design
sprints but let's first of all talk
about what is a design sprint well
that's a great question
design Sprint's started at Google about
five years ago and since then have
become a powerful movement that helped
spur teams at Google our developers and
companies in the industry solve design
problems quickly and what are the stages
of a design sprint so a design sprint
always starts in the planning stage
that's potentially the most important
one the design sprint is run by person
called a sprint master we found that
Sprint's that have a designated person
who is in charge of the event and the
charges in charge of the team lead to
much higher satisfaction and to much
higher deliverables so we always want to
have a point person who is organizing
this could be the p.m. on your team or
this could be your CEO this could be the
designer or it could be you regardless
of whatever role you play the role of
the Sprint master is first to identify
the challenge that the team should be
solving if that is not clear it's very
hard for anyone to make progress second
there are all the Sprint master is to
assemble the team we want to invite all
the right talent and that's the most
important part if you don't have a team
the Sprint doesn't really happen one of
the benefits of the Sprint's is that you
don't always have all the time that you
want but you can get them because the
Sprint's are short you can invite people
who are not from your team so for
example if you and I were running a
sprint and we didn't have a designer or
a researcher we could ask one of our
colleagues who is in another team or
another company to join us for two to
five days no one wakes up in the morning
hoping to have a boring day and when
invite them on the spring they usually
say yes and they have fun and they help
you solve something quickly and really
benefit your team and what are the next
stages after planning okay so the design
sprint framework is based on
understanding of design thinking so
anyone who's the designer might find
these things familiar and very
comfortable to practice the good news is
that if you've never practice design
this is very very easy to learn
generally there's six problem-solving
stages of design sprints
the first is defining the challenge you
have to do that once you've done with
that you start six problem-solving ways
of attacking this challenge the first is
to understand understanding a challenge
is very very important there is a great
quote that I love the test first seek to
understand and then to be understood
many teams fail because they start
attacking they're the products based on
the solutions that they have in their
heads and they do not understand the
customer the requirements and technology
that they have so what you recommend in
spring is to start with lighting talks
you quickly want to hear from everybody
in the team that can represent the
particular perspective and generally the
most useful three first you want to hear
about the business goals we believe that
good design is good business and we
always invite the stakeholders of the
business to tell us about their
objectives in a startup that may be the
CEO of the company or it could be
someone who is really in charge of
revenue right it's useful to have them
there they can bring a valuable
perspective so that the designers are
not running away from the goals of the
company second we want to hear from the
engineers designers and engineers go
together like peanut butter and jelly
you need them in the room because if the
designers create something that the
engineers cannot deliver it sort of
doesn't matter right so the engineers
are there to tell us what is feasible
right now what is the code able to
achieve and what are they able to do
sort of reading the parameters of this
print so this is a business stakeholders
technology what's missing well you can
create a start-up but you cannot create
an audience if you don't have a
perspective of the user so what's really
important is to bring a perspective that
tells us all the potential users of the
of the product that we have a lot of
companies are not sure who their
prospective user is so it useful to
invite the first kind of ideas that you
have about who might this be I'm
impacting and if you're not sure you can
invite different groups for example if
you're creating a news app you can
invite people who are news readers and
who read the New York Times on paper and
people who love reading the
newspapers on their iPad and then people
who don't read the news at all and by
learning what each group needs you're
able to tackle a quiet broad set of
users by hearing their opinions in the
beginning reviewing user research that's
relevant and talking to users directly
this print becomes so much more well
informed and the chances that they'll
miss something are so much lower very
cool so we talked about understanding
and we talked about planning before that
what is the next stage or is that's a
great question the design sprint moves
in a series of of intellectual motions
that allows us to open their minds and
then focus again we believe that we
shouldn't just jump to a solution but we
should learn as much as possible and
then focus on our the best choices and
through that we end up with better
results after than this 10 phase which
opens everybody's mind we have another
phase which is about definition that is
the phase that helps the team understand
what is the strategy they want to pursue
so at this stage we tend to look at the
user journey that we want to take the
user on for example if we're creating an
onboarding flow this may look at the
major steps along the way of someone
finding up for a new service or if
you're creating a new product this may
take you from all the stages that are
key to someone learning about your
product you're discovering it the first
time they use it the first time they
return and what we wish to everyone is
that the users become their master power
for evangelizers where they're coming
all over over and over to the product
and they really enjoy using